i briefly want to mention
that you know from a perspective of
someone
that hires people with bioinformatics
backgrounds
um i think it's important to understand
as a student potentially you might not
really know
what that work might look like what the
projects and what the different
challenges might be
and from the employer's perspective and
the employer here could be either in a
company
or in a lab a research lab a bi of a
research lab they don't really know how
to evaluate someone who's coming to them
and trying to show
their resume or trying to you know come
in someone who knows let's say
bioinformatics or even biotechnology for
that matter
so in a lot of cases
when you're faced with that critical
interaction
what are some of the things that you
actually want to be able to demonstrate
uh one of the things that will always
come up is
the soft skill so to stay right so how
well can you present yourself how well
can you
answer questions or maybe think on the
spot about some question that involves
maybe a non-direct answer right where
you have to show your ability to think
consider the different options come up
with maybe some kind of a
decision that needs to be made
uh and because these kinds of
interactions uh can never fulfill
the role of
uh you know getting to know someone
right the the interactions are very
brief and non-conclusive
that's why
your resume is not enough
that's why just coming to the interview
is not enough in a lot of cases what
happens in the graduate
you know lab where people uh you know
from phd level and onwards are hired
is that people look at the quality of
your research so that might include
participation in research
in papers maybe recommendations from
people who have worked with you before
but for an undergraduate it's very
difficult to
get to that level you probably have
limited participation in research you
probably don't have a lot of references
to share about your ability to work in a
research environment
you probably had minimal opportunities
to conduct research from beginning to
the end and even know about all of the
different stages that go into that kind
of research
and a huge challenge for that is access
to
high quality lab environments
so as an undergraduate student you have
to go through a lot of training and
potentially be in a well-funded
institution to have access to a lot of
that kind of equipment and that's why
bioinformatics is such a critical
opportunity for those who want to
develop those kinds of skills and who
want to stand out
in terms of their capabilities when they
apply for research positions when they
apply for
positions in the industry or even when
they want to continue
their
research and study in a university
so i want to briefly
speak about
the research fellowship program that we
have
that brings the opportunity to work with
big data coming from expert labs
interact with mentors from around the
world that have the background and the
uh kind of track record
and could potentially
give you a recommendation letter at the
end and also the training that we
provide
which will really highlight the
different opportunities in both research
and in industry on how
okay thank you so
um those are the three main components
of this program right and so i'll
briefly kind of show
how these three different components are
used in several different directions
that i think are very promising
in the world of bioinformatics where
really you can see a lot of data coming
to the forefront of biological discovery
and translational research that leads
into biotechnology pharmaceutical
industry and the clinical research
field
so
there are
kind of four of these topics that i will
briefly talk about
precision medicine population health
biotechnology and agriculture and space
and astrobiology
these four have been chosen because
the amount of data the complexity of
data and the reliance on computational
biology skills individuals
infrastructure etc
is growing at an exponential rate
so let's first talk about precision
medicine
what we all know is when we think about
the world medicine is that at the
beginning of that journey in medicine
you
meet a doctor or a nurse
and
uh you as you probably all know when you
go to a doctor you go to a clinic
the first thing that they're going to do
is they're going to try to diagnose the
disease and diagnosing the disease is a
process that involves expertise so a lot
of experience that doctors have dealing
with this specific type of disease it
requires labs where your samples are
being sent to
identify what's going on you know what
exactly is this
and then it also has this
large field of research that constantly
is being updated because people are
finding new meaningful insights about
different types of diseases and and
conditions that we call uh pre-clinical
conditions that lead to disease
so in this field of precision medicine
this whole change from
having
a few indicators that can tell us very
accurately what the disease is that is
changing to
many many more indicators that are much
more precise that's where the word
precision comes from in the term
precision medicine but also because they
are so precise they are specific to
very small groups or even individuals
and that's where the word personalized
medicine comes from
so those two parallel directions of
precision
and personalized medicine
converge in specific chronic diseases
and those could be cancer metabolic
diseases
and others and and they include a
combination of various markers that can
help us understand the risk how
predisposed someone is to have a disease
happen early on
complexity of disease progression so how
likely are they to recover fast or
develop some complications
but also importantly to two very
specific and immediate needs in this
field which is accurate diagnosis and
then effective treatment selection
because it's important to select
treatment that actually is going to be
effective
so in the world of precision medicine
bioinformatics and biomedical analytics
play a huge role because so much data at
every interaction is being collected
that someone needs to make sense of that
data and that someone today are very
specialized genetic counselors and maybe
clinicians
doctors
sorry
but ultimately this field continues to
develop and in between those
interactions there's going to be a lot
of opportunity to number one conduct
research that leads to identification of
these markers
and
also
to technicians that will have to deal
with this kind of data process this data
analyze this data and be able to say
something about this data so i think
this field has a huge potential for
those of you that are interested in
medical school that are interested in md
phd programs but also that are
interested in
research that has the potential to
change the way that people are diagnosed
and treated for precision medicine the
second area that is very obviously right
now being changed in front of our eyes
is the world of public health
or population health where we see this
pandemic and others really change our
reliance on molecular diagnostics to
identify specific strains to identify
populations at more risk
to understand new approaches to vaccine
design right we're seeing it in front of
our eyes and so i think it's obvious
that in this field there's going to be a
tremendous change as we move forward in
terms of how much data and how much
analysis of that data is being done to
really be able to anticipate react more
fast to these kinds of outbreaks but
also to be able to design new
therapeutics and interventions like
vaccines to slow
the transmission of diseases
another important area is the field of
biotechnology and agriculture we're kind
of combining them together but really i
want to first talk about agriculture
so as you know with climate change
there's a huge concern about the ability
of crops to remain resilient
with the recent increase in the prices
of fertilizers we see a lot of people
turning to
bacterial type fertilizers that change
the microbiome of the soil
but because
land is so different right there's
different types of toxicity acidity
amount of water being available in
different fields
now we understand that we can
effectively measure those different
kinds of
indicators and identify the best crops
for the best portion of land
we can increase productivity of those
crops and we can make those crops more
nutritious more resilient and
easier to grow
and so the field of precision
agriculture is really emerging as a
field that will be dominated by data
but importantly also by others data
you can see the number of crops that
their genomes have been sequenced to be
able to ask these questions is growing
every year
and you can see that the ability to
design new crops and make
specific features of those crops
kind of
become more attuned to the needs of a
specific region those kinds of studies
are emerging you can see a huge issue
with uh forests around the world where
they are being attacked by insects and
they're being uh you know subjected to
harsh climate conditions um and
obviously all of that ties into the
quality of the environment that we live
in
finally
i want to briefly mention space and
astrobiology
so when we think about space we don't
typically think about
medical needs we don't think about
quality of life right i mean astronauts
go there and they train for years to be
even considered
but eventually when they're there you
know they have to deal with these very
harsh conditions and those include
conditions of microgravity conditions of
radiation
really limited food supply and diversity
of food so there's really
a
very unique
kind of combination of factors that we
know affect human health in a profound
way
and that's why there's a huge effort in
not only building technology to get us
to space but also developing
methodologies to understand how space
travel will affect health and how we can
adapt to these conditions to be able to
grow food maybe on the space station
maybe
as you probably have seen the first
arabidopsis plant has recently been
grown in moon soil here on earth but it
was on in moon soil and and that is a
significant study that shows that it is
possible to grow food on the moon
theoretically
but also there have been studies about
the microbiome
because there's an issue with
different types of microbes kind of
living in the space station
international space station right so
there's a huge interest and funding
available for those kinds of studies
and in fact many of our interns and
fellows have been able to conduct
research studies using data that nasa is
actually providing free of charge to the
community at large
kind of encouraging students researchers
to be asking questions about what's
happening in space and how can we
understand and better prepare
for the type of space travel that is
envisioned by these space agencies
so
to
start addressing the variety of topics
that we just discussed i think uh dr
raghavendran already provided you with a
clear framework on how to be able to
address some of those questions but i
want to re review again a couple of the
slides that you already shared but
maybe focus on them in a little bit of a
different fashion so the first thing
that he mentioned was
the challenge with selecting a topic we
just saw
uh four major domains a lot of potential
directions and a lot of interesting
questions that could be asked and i
think as you get to know every one of
these domains and you
are able to study the research
publications out there that come out or
have come out in the recent years you
will find that a lot of those papers
they focus on organizing and
categorizing different topics relevant
to that domain so if you take the field
of precision medicine or population
health or
biotechnology and agriculture or space
omics you will find that a lot of those
kinds of experiments and studies that
have made a
significant impact on that field will be
categorized they will say
this is what has been uh you know the
topic this is why
these are the types of experiments that
have been done to address that topic or
question
the second thing
is that in the discussion portion of
those publications you will find a lot
of times
the
reviewers and the people authors who
write these papers they will actually
identify
gaps unanswered questions controversies
and debates around specific topics and
those are really
the most interesting topics that you
potentially as a student or as a
young researcher can start to think
about
a lot of those
are limited by the amount of data that
is available a lot of those are limited
by the types of experiments that are
possible to conduct
but this field is growing is developing
very rapidly and so it is
easy to imagine how
a publication can uh only focus on a
small portion of an unanswered question
and the rest of the data that is
available from the experiment has yet to
be analyzed in a specific way to be able
sorry to contribute to those answers so
i think that
bioinformatics and the availability of
this public domain data really allows us
to leverage
these
high quality
expensive data sets that are now
publicly available to be able to ask
very specific impactful questions that
we can actually answer and i think that
this research fellowship program is
designed specifically around that kind
of need it is designed to help you
identify those understand the context of
where the question is being asked find
those data sets and then be able to
conduct
analysis to be able to answer those
kinds of questions